yeah welcome to a new blitz game hmm Wow
alcohol I was briefly thinking is there
some offbeat line that I could could
play but down let's just play normal the
the sameish recently got played a lot at
them candidates swidler played some some
good games interesting games yeah they
mostly play this rook see one line
nowadays what what no it's this move I
think on b5 there's c5 and now they
often play with e 60
uh-huh interesting
yeah well rook takes this normal move
can what about d5 and if F is got 95 95
not c4 so I check with the rook yeah
black gum if he plays in this way needs
to really find some direct justification
for this because from a strategic point
of view is already busted on the CFR but
he's better developed I'm still only one
so maybe he can open up something
something tactical in a way um well II
five where do you go with your night go
to h5 the number then I go g4 then I've
got an extra night so rookie aid is
probably not the way to go unless I'm
overlooking something
no it seems I didn't overlook something
it's really winning right yeah computers
hot Sun plus to winning the night yeah
he cannot he cannot take on I don't know
how another the theory here maybe black
has has some some some point e 6am
maybeee six and then rupee eight Bishop
f8 or something it just looks it just
looks terribly ugly this is this
weaknesses on to see file but of course
white is very slow with development gap
this was a really short game yeah still
anyway thanks for watching